lady gaga and her fiance Christian
Kirino have split according to multiple
reports a source tells ET quote there
was no drama between the two the
relationship just came to an end
rumours first swirled that the two had
called it quits when eagle-eyed fans
noticed that the singer was not wearing
her engagement ring at the Grammy Awards
the star is born' actress also failed to
thank Kirino in her acceptance speech
after her song shallow won for the award
for best pop duo or group performance
thank you thank you so much
Kirino did not attend the Grammys even
though Gaga brought him as her date to
many of the other events this awards
season including the Screen Actors Guild
Awards and the Golden Globes I
understand your fiance is with you
tonight yes he's here he's here he's
wonderful that make the night even more
special of course to share it with the
one that you love you know it's just a
beautiful evening and he was so
supportive through the entire filming
process and you know I loved him very
much
What did he say to you about tonight is
he just so proud he said enjoy yourself
but he said yes and on valentine's day
instead of sharing photos with her
fiance the star reveals that she'd had a
permanent piece of a star is born' inked
on her body that's mama monster debuting
a massive tat on her spine that pays
tribute to her role in the acclaimed
musical drama
I don't sing my own songs why I just
don't feel comfortable she captioned the
shot on Instagram quote happy
Valentine's Day a tattoo toast to la vie
and rose by the beautiful at winter
stone my spinal cord is now a rose Gaga
revealed her engagement to Kirino at
ELLs 25th annual women in Hollywood
celebration in October 2018 when she
thanked her fiance during her speech
everybody at table 5
my fiancee Christian the singer and the
talent agent were first spotted getting
cozy at a Kings of Leon concert in early
2017 after ending her five-year
relationship with Taylor Kinney in July
2016 a source at the time told ET quote
this relationship is different because
Christian understands her on a more
intimate level she trusts him fully and
feels totally secure around him
[Music]